all right youngins your boy is back
outside in these 2K 23 streets you
already know what type of time we are I
ain't even gonna waste your time let's
get it now let me tell you something let
me tell you something the first thing
you're not gonna do is come out here
disrespect me put your hands up my
brother the game just came out you can't
be just not having your hands up my
brother now come down to this post
office let me show you something real
quick post office is open on 2K 23. let
me show you something hop step fake put
your hands up my brother my brother my
brother my brother you're gonna have to
block me if my brother that that hands
up stuff I'm immune to it okay I got
hands up immunity this year my brother
not coming stop moving around so much my
brother you what are you scared my
brother
come on now now let's make a return
visit back down to this post office let
me show you my footwork with the past
fake the shoulder fake the jab this my
brother y'all gotta put your hands up
you know what I'm sick and tired of your
defensive negligence just get off my
court